hello everyone and welcome to game four
of the new
chess classic finals knockouts it's
magnus cross and versus hikaru nakamura
and if you've been following the
coverage so far
magnus retaliated because he car won the
first game second game ended in draw and
then
magnus bonds back in the third one and
see since hikaru lost to the first match
now hikaru needs a win in the final game
at the
fourth tie breaks or if magnus gets a
draw or he gets a win in this game then
it's all over
so let's see what happens here magnus
has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 so let's see how he
car deals with uh carlson's e4
hikaru goes for c5 he goes for the
sicilian defense
and we have c3 for magnus the alapin
variation of the ceiling so
trying to throw hikaru off guard we have
g6 and now
d4 striking in the center we have
captures captures and now
d5 by hikaru with e5 grabbing more space
in the center
and bishop to g7 now we have knight to
f3 and now comes
knight to h6 this is how hikaru decides
to develop this knight
we have bishop to b5 with check and now
comes
knight to c6 we have castles by both
players so castles castles
and h3 by magnus stopping bishop to g4
and here
hikaru goes for f6 and this is the
crucial idea here
uh when playing this with black you want
to attack
a white strong center even at the cost
of pushing your f6
pawn so here magnus captures we have
captures captures and the knight
to c3 carlson continues development we
have g5 and now
rook to e1 and here uh there is a game
where g4 was played and i
think this is in fact the strongest move
in the position
uh but uh hikaru decides against that he
goes for queen to d6 he doesn't want to
over push it and burn all of his bridges
a bit too soon so he decides to wait
with the g4 idea so queen to d6 this is
now a new move in the position
so already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game so let's see how
magnus deals with it he goes bishop to
a4
now with uh he corresponds being so
weirdly placed here he might be having
some ideas of bishop to c2 queen d3
and maybe just going after this h7 pawn
for a moment this is not possible
as long as this knight is on h6 you
always have this defensive resource of
bishop to f5
attacking this queen so for the moment
this is not a problem
king to h8 by hikaru and now comes
bishop to b3 first putting more pressure
to the beat after the d5 pawn
knights the e7 defending and now queen
to e2 adding another attacker here
uh knight h to g8 uh that's why the king
was
pushed to h8 but also to get away from
this diagonal
and now queen to b5 magnus adds a third
attacker to the d5 pawn and hikaru needs
to defend it we have rook to d8
and now comes bishop to d2 now that all
of his pieces are
joining in the attack magnus needs to
bring one more the last piece into the
game and that's this rook on a1
so here b6 hikaru is ready to develop
the light square bishop and
now knight to e2 this knight can now
come to g3 and from g3 to
f5 and h5 depending on what black plays
so here a5 by hikaru and bishop to c2
now by magnus again there's this always
this idea of queen to d3
but as long as this bishop is here on c8
bishop to f5 will be possible because
the knight covers this square
so here hikaru just attacks the queen
bishop to a6
uh now uh queen d3 is not possible and
now queen back to b3 we have rook d
to c8 and rook ate the c1 so the rook
is inter in the game finally and the
situation on the clock is magnus some
seven minutes
and hikaru ten minutes on the clock so
let's see uh how he car
continues we have rooked the c6
preparing to double up on the c
file and the bishop back to b1 magnus
very happy to trade here
we have rook 8 to c8 and now a trade on
c6 we have captures captures and
now uh knight to c3 you could go to g3
like we said then the knight can come
to these squares but magnus prefers the
the more solid knights the c3
uh we have uh bishop back to c8 this
bishop has to
uh you know get activated somehow so
hikaru switches it over to
keep attack to continue attacking the
king side and
again g4 or maybe f5 and g4 or maybe
even
h5 and g4 might be ideas in the future
so magnus goes bishop to d3
now preparing queen c2 to put more
pressure on h7
and now queen to d8 uh we have
a queen to c2 by magnus and then now as
the h7 pawn is under attack just h6
this is how hikaru defends it and now
queen to d1
you don't really want your queen on c2
so here bishop to e6 and
now queen to e2 now the queen is very
active
on the e file along with the rook so now
bishop back to f7
and now knight to b5 we have knight to
g6 by hikaru and now
queen back to d1 now magnus wants to
bring the queen over to b1
and then with this bishop battery put
more pressure on the king side here
we have knight eight to e7 and now queen
to b1 as planned and this is a super
paralyzing move
uh because this knight now cannot move
because we just win material here
and it's not easy for hikaru to find the
move he goes queen to d7
uh and now comes b4 uh magnus wants to
open up the the queen side
the king the queen side here we have a
captures the bishop captures
and now h5 hikaru now probably ready to
push g4 here
uh we have knight back to c3 by magnus
now shifting the knight
back uh the g4 the g3 to help out with
the defense
but now not g4 right away if you push g4
right away then the knight comes here
and then it's just
really really bad uh because well uh
this knife cannot move otherwise the e7
knight becomes super weak
and other than that it's uh just uh just
a incredibly difficult
position to play for black so instead
after knight to c3 we rook the c7 by
hikaru
and now comes knight to e2 and now
magnus really wants to bring this knight
over to g3
so instead of g4 hikaru plays h4 and
takes away the g3 square from
magnus's knight and now while magnus
could go for some knight h2 to g for
action he decides to just straight out
win the b6 pawn so bishop captures a
knight on e7
knight captures and queen captures on b6
and now magnus is very happy
not only with his position in this game
but also with his uh
general position in the match because uh
well he's up upon
and he's ready to push his past a pawn
to victory and if he
doesn't do anything about that well it's
just a
much better position for white hikaru
does have the bishop pair
but it's uh well most definitely not
fully operational so bishop the h5 by
hikaru now ready to pick up this knight
to open up uh white's king's side but
now
knight the h2 magnus doesn't even want
to try anything here
uh you could allow for example white to
capture this
but black to capture this but there's
really no point and now queen captures
is impossible because the rook is
hanging so maybe
it is playable but there's no reason to
allow
black any such chances so knight stay h2
and now hikaru continues with f5 now
hopefully g4 is coming uh and now we
have queen to b5
magnus now offers uh sorry uh bishop to
b5
attacking the the queen here so the
queen has to keep an eye on the rook on
c7 so queen to c8
and here uh he just allows magnus a bit
too much here
safest was just rook to b7 to trade
queens here
uh but it doesn't really help you after
captures and captures uh white is still
up upon
and uh even though black will probably
not lose this black
will most definitely not win this so
hikaru has to look for his chances
elsewhere when after bishop to b5 we
have queen to c8
but now we have queen to d6 by magnus
and now again it's very very difficult
to find a move here for black hikaru is
up on time
magnet has some four minutes on the
clock where sd card has seven
but again it's not uh
not easy to find the moves here so
knights the g8
once this knight moves then there's
going to be a nice attack here on this
knight
so knight back to g8 and now knight to
f3 now magnus says okay
uh either you capture this knight or
then i'm just gonna
uh play play it anywhere and then just
have a you know
beautifully winning position so hikaru
grabs it
but it's uh off of little importance we
have g
capture sun f3 and now knight to f6 by
hikaru
but now magnus just pushes a4 and now
there's
really not all that much for black to do
here your last attempt is to once again
play g4 here this is
basically the hikaru's entire plan for
for the entire game but he never got
to push g4 so here he played rook day
seven
magnus offered the draw or maybe he
carved over the draw and then magnus
accepted i don't really know
uh but uh doesn't really matter because
here the game ended in a draw because he
car wasn't interested in continuing it
he knows that it's a losing position for
black and the magnus of course
very happily accepted it uh because he
doesn't gain anything by winning and by
drawing it he
wins the entire match so here the game
ended in draw and the magnus is the
winner of the new inches classic
which goes a long way as he's been
really struggling to
get a nice victory in a strong
tournament uh you know ever
ever since he turned 30. uh but yeah
here you resign
you you don't resign but your position
is worse and there's really not all that
much to play with
for example if rook to c1 just attacking
the queen
you can move the queen let's see queen
to f8 now queen e5
and now this is under attack you can't
really do anything about that if you
move the knight then the this
falls if you push it then this falls
there's really no there's no move here
for black
and that's uh i mean that that's just it
you have to play something like knight
g8 then the deep on false
uh then you have uh the the past the
deep on and also the past a pawn so
black really has nothing to
to hope for here of course hikaru knows
that and after rook day seven
uh he resigned the game uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it ended this very very short coverage
of the noon chess classic
um like i said i i tried to to
move as quickly as possible to to cover
as many games as
as possible but in the end i was only
able to cover the finals
but now that this is over i'm going to
try to improve everything as much as
possible to get
the room to have as a little echo as
possible i
i've seen you guys in the comments you
gave some very very nice suggestions so
i'm going to go through all of that
and i already have some ideas but you
know i've seen some of you guys
are really into that and that you really
know what you're talking about so
that will definitely come in handy and
also i will you know
improve the background over time so you
know more things are coming don't uh
worry not and uh meadows old stuff is
also uh coming i i had
the dry cleaned but it's still not ready
they said they will
have it next week so uh no worries
uh but yeah i just wanted to mention
that uh thank you for being so patient
and for you know all of your great
suggestions in the comments
i would like to thank colin lancaster
dustin lackey rob toy
tom derelau and ricardo ruffles for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day